no slides first and foremost I'm very
flattered to be here I think this is a
very powerful conference and what Tim
and crew are putting together here I
think is extremely relevant and very
very important and I'm really really
humbled to get this time to Yap with you
guys just a little quick context because
I know I don't have a whole lot of time
I was born in Belarus in the former
Soviet Union and I came here in 1978
when I was three years old my family
lived in a studio apartment with eight
family members about the size of this
couch and it was tough and we worked
really hard and my dad got a small
liquor store in New Jersey I was very
entrepreneurial lemonade stands baseball
cards all that stuff and then my dad
dragged my ass into the liquor store
when I was 14 paid me two bucks an hour
to bag ice for 12 hours a day
that sucked and eventually I started
getting passionate about wine because
people collected it and that's where I
came from so that brought me my interest
I launched winelibrary.com in 1997 and a
lot of the talk about what social media
can bring to the table right now it
reminds me a whole lot of 97 when people
were talking about whether Amazon had a
shot of winning or are these web things
a fad and I think why I'm here today and
what I want to talk about is how it's
relevant to to this universe what what I
think is really intriguing is that I
built this large business grew the
business from a couple million dollars a
year to a 60 million dollar a year
business in a very short period of time
leveraging web 1.0 lots of ads having a
site all that good jazz I want to buy
the New York Jets and on my 30th
birthday I realized that I couldn't
because wine shipping laws in America
suck and I can't ship wine to Boston or
Maryland or many other places so if
anybody in the room here can fix that
that'd be awesome but what I what was
interesting was I turned 30 and I
freaked out because I didn't think that
that model would get me to where I
wanted to be because of the restrictive
market and I decided to build the one
thing I knew that could not be taken
away from me which
my personal brand and on February 2006 I
sat in front of a camera and drank wine
for 20 minutes reviewing the three wines
and decided I was going to build my
personal brand by building Wine Library
TV somehow four years later hundreds of
thousands of people watched that every
single day
it grew my personal brand but what was
most important and most relevant to this
room in my opinion is how I went about
building that brand and why it's so
relevant to elections to this space to
the transparency that offers such
amazing amazing opportunity in my
opinion America is right now the brand
that my parents were sold when we came
here from a business standpoint which is
where I do a lot of consulting and where
my career has led me to entrepreneurs
and business have so much more
opportunity because of the World Wide
Web the internet the web the consumer
web is 15 years old it's only been 15 or
16 years since AOL spammed
our actual mailboxes with a CD and it
has completely changed the landscape
there are going to be enormous amounts
of people that win elections in November
leveraging things like Facebook and
Twitter and I'll be very honest with you
I could care less about Facebook or
Twitter I could get her absolute less
I'm not a techie the most techy I was
when I was 18 years old was I had Sega
Genesis and played NHL 94 I did not grow
up with an apple it was not my world I
am NOT romanced by this platform I'm
always romanced by the message and we
are living in an outrageously
transparent world you're gonna hear a
lot of smart people the two ladies
before me were amazing you're gonna hear
a ton more but what I'm passionate about
in my short 10 minutes if I could
communicate anything very much like you
know the thing I'm trying to communicate
to my clients like the National Hockey
League or Campbells or Forbes some of
the clients I have with vaynermedia is
this shit's changed the ship has sailed
this is here the ability for us to
communicate with each other is on like
Donkey Kong and that is absolutely
the fundamentally changed everything and
we've seen it change dramatically the
opportunities in business my web show is
watched by more people than are
subscribed to Wine Spectator and Robert
Parker combined I was able to disrupt my
marketplace in 24 months leveraging the
power of these tools and that was oh six
pre-twitter and I was scared to use
Facebook because I didn't want to be the
creepy old guy peddling wines to the
kids so it was it's very very important
to understand how it is such a game
changer and the ability for somebody to
win an election the ability for somebody
to rally a cause right now doesn't
necessarily stand on dollars alone and
money for the first time in a very long
time has been subsidized it's been
stopped and that is a very important
fact Hollywood how many of you in this
room know what the movie Bo rat was
please raise your hands don't be lazy
thank you Sacha Baron Cohen made a movie
Borat very successful he followed it up
with a movie called Bruno it opened on a
Wednesday night it is the largest
grossing movie for a Wednesday night in
cinema history the next day
Thursday the movie collapsed worst
Thursday ever for a Wednesday opening
movie what Hollywood knew was this if
they threw enough money at marketing
they had to three weeks to pull in
enough revenue against that spend and
the movie could be successful literally
nine months ago a year ago when this
movie came out and they saw those
numbers there are thirty to a hundred
projects shelved because the movie sucks
and what happened with Bruno was people
came out of the theater that Wednesday
night and started facebooking texting
and twittering that the movie sucked
and nobody went and saw it word of mouth
is on steroids now things travel and
there's absolutely no hiding there is no
opportunity for a candidate to have a
more conservative message within their
state upstate and then go a little more
liberal down here because every one of
those talks are going to be seen
critiqued and
transparency is messin with people
because just like the brands that I do
work for and just like I did for a long
time buying full-page ads in the New
York Times or The Wine Spectator we have
all collectively been in the push
business for the last 70 and 80 years we
have a message we pound it down your
damn throat and you're gonna either
accept it in a win or you're gonna lose
now we all live in a completely
upside-down game we are all in the pool
business and giving a crap and actually
caring is going to scale I'm writing a
book right now just to shut up everybody
about the ROI of social media once and
for all it's called the Thank You
economy if you are not aware if you are
confused if you're baffled or curious on
how leveraging these tools can impact
your business your brand your kin and
see your cause then you are not paying
attention to the way it's always been
how things shift people love to draw
lines in the sand please don't be lazy
on me you're leaving after this and I'm
not going over time like the other girls
I'm gonna leave in a second so please
raise your hand how many people in this
room said the following things to
themselves I will never get a Facebook
account please raise your hand right now
don't be lazy if you said that to
yourself raise them higher how many of
those people now have a Facebook account
please raise your hands how many people
said this doozie and some of your being
lazy so raise your hand cuz this is a
real good one you don't want to admit it
how many of you said I will never get a
cellphone why would I want anybody to
contact me anytime they want please
raise your hand don't lie please raise I
love you honestly this time thank you of
those people just curious how many of
you do not have a cellphone do not 100 I
see it I see you nice work
we as human beings are very good at
drawing lines in the sand what I'm
interested in and where I always pay
attention to is where we drawing lines
and realizing we're gonna cross them
I think this sector is the next line to
have a lot of jump over and sure you
know a lot of people talk about Obama's
campaign or I'm from Jersey you're mayor
Booker has done an amazing job
leveraging Twitter he's like shovelling
people's driveways you know when they
tweet that didn't come doing nice things
but we're about to see a heavy movement
it's gonna happen fast and quick and
people are gonna be confused how it
happened you should not be confused
we're living in it right now and it's
not stopping for anybody I hope you have
a great day love your family
[Applause]